welcome to this video against pointe du
jour pour du jour I don't I don't speak
any French unfortunately I always some
yeah nowadays I think why didn't I take
at least some courses in French so that
I'm at least have some basic
understanding but at the time it didn't
really occur to me okay on what the heck
am I playing here we've been a main line
rui what thinking about French in school
um okay plate h3 head to to prevent the
pure marshal a check now we're back in
the main position to move 9 enter is
playing the G Goren let's see what line
my own line here Schneider 96 the
ancient Rubenstein variation Brooke
piece mm-hmm I don't know now let's
let's let's close the position it's very
often a good idea after but should be
seven to play d5 closing the position
down and asking this Bishop what it is
doing um like quite often yeah exactly
um those for a quick f5 maybe he's doing
that here no it seems that he wants to
put the bishop on the night on c5 yeah
this is also possible so it's a bit
unusual timing to do a bit unusual to
take they have six night over
ok let's see I have quite some pieces
geared towards the Kings side maybe am I
can initiate some plain like h4 h5 or
sometimes you can even go with a night
sec okay he's regrouping the bishop on
b7 this is probably the right idea I try
to prepare a form
why it's not not really doing much
against that not quite sure what he
should have done but ok I can also take
with the Queen getting more pieces near
the king yeah why not look to everyone I
need to look on their farm I'll play
Bishop g5 where are you going
maybe 97 okay let's play this first it's
probably better non-threatening Bishop
g5 if you move the light it's going to
explode on f7 okay yes still if I play
Bishop g5 where do you move it cannot go
to d7 f7a saying
and yeah a chancy move really what
what's black supposed to play now
yeah I think why it's just winning here
it's got no place to go with 90 x
night h5 very very ugly move
yeah he lost many moves here with with
the night bishop and and so on didn't
really find a black raised on yes didn't
really find a suitable set up against
against this active plan not quite sure
where it begins I guess 97 is still ok
but it gets it gets tricky really
quickly I think yeah this is quite often
the right way to go I really question
this 97 move still because well this
night is supposed to go to c5 but why
then play night back to d7 so I'm not
clear to me after that but it gets it
gets very tricky maybe 97 big as strange
as it looks but why does unquestionably
better here I've got all pieces here
with the with some play on the clink
side yeah this is probably already
winning our computer agrees nowhere no
defense they are the best line according
to the computer is this this is a plain
nub played terrible
yeah and after that yeah he resigned and
there's no move really can can go here
check so she'll probably just this with
a five to come simply simply simply gone
also this is just terrible night on the
aid yeah he is simply a regrouped his
pieces in a wrong way man lost much time
in the process alright thanks for
watching